I've been using the iPhone 14 pro Max
for the last couple of months and I have
absolutely been loving it especially
with the new always on display and the
new Dynamic Island and I would recommend
it to anybody looking to buy a new
iPhone right now there's just a little
problem you may have noticed that over
the weekend especially on Black Friday
many Shoppers could not find Apple's
latest iPhone at Apple retail stores
which is the headline of this article
right here in fact if you try to buy an
iPhone 14 pro Max right now you
literally won't get it until after
Christmas and that by itself might be
enough to make some of you want to wait
until the next iPhone 15 lineup with all
of these shortages right here because
you've got to wait over a month to get
the new iPhone and in this video I'm
going to be going through the different
features teachers especially the camera
features of the 15 Pro Max model because
we just got some new leaks about that
but if you were wondering why we're
getting all of these delays with the new
iPhones specifically according to Wed
Bush security they say that inventory
was 25 to 30 percent below normal in
many Apple Stores over the Black Friday
weekend and if you want to know why well
check this out look what is happening
over in China right now yes this is at
the Foxconn iPhone Factory there is some
protests some Rebellion going on and it
basically has slowed iPhone production
to a halt we literally have Chinese
citizens fighting with the police this
is a bad situation and my heart goes out
to everybody living out there hopefully
the living conditions change and get
better and if all of that is making you
decide to skip out on the 14 pro Max and
just wait until next year well let's get
into the brand new redesign that we
should expect specifically showing off
some different renders from some
different sources and I'm gonna talk
about my own personal predictions for
how they're going to deal with the
design and the camera bump last week on
Monday we got a huge leak from shrimp
Apple Pro on Twitter who actually leaked
the dynamic Island he was the first to
do that saying that the iPhone 15 could
feature a titanium chassis yes just like
the Apple watch Ultra with curved rear
edges which right now we actually have
square and flat edges all around with
the flat sides so that's going to make
it more comfortable to hold your iPhone
now check this out nine to five Mac
actually showed off the design of the
iPhone 5c where it's flat on the front
and Cur served on the back which was a
really nice design and especially
holding it in your hands but going
directly to the source shrimp Apple
Pro's leak he said that for the new
iPhone 15 the back Edge is going to be
rounded like you can see this is the
iPhone right now and it's going to move
over to this rounded design style and he
says it's still gonna have a back glass
and he personally thinks that this will
create a really beautiful Edge
transition from the back over to the
camera bump and I'll show you guys how I
can imagine this in just a minute and
with that said he actually commented on
a render created by John juhan of the
iPhone 15. check it out you can see this
rounded Edge design on the back and just
by looking at it it feels comfortable
just look at that it feels so nice
however this looks like it's metal but
of course it is still gonna be glass on
the back and in his case he's saying
that this is a pretty good idea of what
it's going to look like but not actually
what the final design will look like
because this does not feature the new
Periscope camera or the solid state
buttons that we've had some rumors of so
just keep this with a grain of salt
because it should look a little bit
differently and I'll explain why it's a
compliment that idea Gus palmy created
this video showing these curved edges on
the side look at that this is definitely
a different design but it's not how I
would do it now if you're one of those
people who don't want to wait for the
new iPhone 15 lineup or you hate this
new curved back design and you're just
going to be buying a 14 pro Max instead
or of course if you already have one of
these then our partner Taurus currently
has a killer deal on their new u-pro o
stand case series with a genius Max safe
ring design which comes with a hidden
built-in stand that's completely flush
with the back of the case but you can
pull the ring down and use it as a stand
with three different angles ranging from
40 to 120 degrees as well as using it
sideways like this for watching videos
or whatever else and the most impressive
part is that the hinge is very strong so
it holds that basically any of those
angles even with the pro Max and the
ring itself includes very strong and 52
howback magnets for your macsafe
accessories and of course it's
compatible with your macsafe fast
Chargers and the Final Touch is that you
can use it as a grip with just one
finger through the ring so that you
don't drop your iPhone and if you forget
to use the grip and you do drop it the
case itself is shock proof with three
times military standard drop protection
so go ahead and check them out using the
links below now getting back to the
problem with these iPhone 15 lineup
renders shrimp Apple Pro actually
commented and said that it's using old
design features like the old three times
telephoto lens instead of a 5x Periscope
camera and then somebody actually asked
them if the camera setup on the back is
Gonna Change will the Periscope camera
mean a fourth lens or will it still have
only three well according to shrimp it's
likely still three lens because Apple
can make a crop times 12 megapixel photo
without any problem which we've actually
experienced and the 2x photos are
actually really really good so if the
ultra has a periscope camera then it has
to change and the Periscope takes up a
lot of horizontal space so what I'm
going to do is split this up into two
different scenarios or two different
options for how the iPhone would look
like based on it still being three lens
or potentially four lenses renders by
shyles just posted the sneak peek
preview of what the new iPhone 15 design
could look like and as you can see it
has a super nice curved Edge design with
the metal kind of merging into curved
back glass this looks absolutely
beautiful and you can see from this top
view wow that looks incredible and you
can see that nice curve right here on
the back and this of course has assumes
that the three camera design is here to
stay with the telephoto being replaced
with a periscope which will likely be
kind of hidden inside of the iPhone and
just to give you guys a sneak preview of
how it could look colored look at that
from shylesh that looks absolutely
gorgeous now here's where we run into a
little bit of a problem with that design
Ming chiko said that the iPhone 15 Pro
Max will exclusively get a new 12
megapixel telephoto lens with six times
optical zoom and sensor shift
stabilization and if that is true I
believe that it has to have a four
camera design not three but four because
Apple can't go straight from the 1X lens
with two times crop all the way to a 6X
optical zoom lens there's a massive
range that they're missing out on in
between that and 5x photos will look
absolutely terrible even worse than they
are now if Apple's replacing the 3x with
a 6X so I believe there's going to be
the 0.5 x Ultra wide then the 1X They're
Gonna Keep the 3x zoom lens and then
they're gonna add a fourth six x lens to
basically nail the quality down
throughout the entire range of Zoom it
is going to be absolutely killer and
here is how I believe they are going to
do the design unfortunately I'm working
with renders by shylash right now to try
to get those done but they're not done
so I'm just going to explain it to you
and you can leave it up to your
imagination now I don't know if you guys
remember those old leaks that turned out
to be wrong about the 14 pro Max having
protruding glass on the back and the
front well this is how I imagine the 15
Pro Max I believe that the glass is
going to protrude out of the back
however this Edge right here is going to
be curved into the metal chassis all the
way around and it might meet up somehow
being curved on both of them I'm not
sure but I believe that the camera bumps
will stick out right out the flush glass
with no glass camera bump like we have
right now with the edge glass that's
going away it's going to be flat on the
back and that is going to give Apple
more room for a fourth Periscope camera
I think apple is going to find a way to
combine either the lidar and the camera
into one or they're going to move the
flash down next to the lidar and make
this black window kind of like this
pill-shaped cutout right above right
here with the entire Periscope camera
being on the inside that's how I think
it's going to look like and I'm working
on those renders for you guys right now
but before then I do want to go through
a couple of other leaks that we just got
about the camera system naked Asia just
published that the iPhone 15 is going to
be using a state-of-the-art image sensor
from Sony for better low light
performance and essentially it's going
to make the saturation signal get
doubled within each pixel allowing it to
capture more light to cut down on under
exposure and over exposure which is
going to help with a lot of back lit
photos so that's one piece that's going
to be getting added to the iPhone 15.
now there was also a test that was done
comparing the max safe charging
performance between the 14 pro Max and
the 13 Pro Max and apparently Apple
really did work on the stability and the
Energy Efficiency and heat on the new 14
pro Max so this means that Apple could
easily upgrade the wireless charging
speed of Max safe maybe going all the
way up to 20 watt Max safe wireless
charging with the next iPhone 15 lineup
and then on top of that apparently it
Apple September event Apple was
originally going to release a new Apple
pencil codenamed maker priced at about
49 with no pressure sensing no battery
needed using a chip to power the stylus
from the screen similar to the Samsung S
Pen and apparently Apple was going to
give this new apple pencil support for
the iPhone for the first time ever but
apparently the project was terminated
right before the launch it's even said
that they had close to 1 million levels
of stock of this new apple pencil and
they should now all apparently be
scrapped which to me doesn't make any
sense at all there's a good chance that
Apple could delay this new apple pencil
an entire year until the iPhone 15
lineup and maybe even give us apple
pencil support for the first time and
maybe even just for the pro Max model
which could end up up being called the
ultra who really knows but I can only
hope and then making it even better
according to Majin Buu there is a chance
that the new iPhone 15 Ultra or Pro Max
could support Thunderbolt 4 with up to
80 gigabits per second of bandwidth
which is absolutely insane because right
now it's limited to 40 gigabits per
second so 80 would just be crazy so I
don't know what Apple's gonna do but if
they give us that amount of bandwidth
it's going to be a massive massive
upgrade so there you guys go those were
the leaks and rumors for the 15 Pro Max
and let me know Down Below in the
comments if you're deciding to wait
until the iPhone 15 lab gets released or
just buy the new iPhone 14 pro Max maybe
even with this new Taurus awesome case
thanks for watching click the circle
about to subscribe for more videos like
this one check out one of those two
right there and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]